And the two tools we'll be looking at most of here are the E-POS and ILLIAD tools.
So they're used for storyboarding within Sequencer.
We have an Epic MegaGran recipient and partner with Praxinus, which provides additional tools
that expand Unreal Engine capabilities, including using Sequencer to generate content for storyboards
and animatics.
So to get started, we need to grab the free E-POS and ILLIAD plugins from the marketplace
on the Epic Games launcher.
We want to make sure they're enabled.
To open the plugins window, you just go to edits at the top of your editor, go down to
plugins, which is at the bottom of the page.
And then you just want to enable these two plugins.
Potential recommendation here as well is you could enable the stylus and tablet plugin
when using either Wacom or non-wacom tablet devices and it'll make that storyboarding
process much more straightforward.
You may have to restart your editor as well and then upon restarting, you'll have access
to the tools that we'll be talking about here today.
So a few editor preferences that you might want to set here.
If you just go to your editor preferences, again found under the edit bar at the top
of your editor, go down to editor preferences and if you just type in Sequencer in that
search bar at the top, you'll be able to find some shortcuts that we're wanting to set here.
And so we want to disable the up, down, left and right movements in the shortcut settings
and just kind of try and mirror your settings as what we have here.
And then we also have the project setting where you can get fine project settings.
Again alongside where the plugins and editor preferences are, go to edit, project settings
and we want to enable the support UV from hit results.
So if you just type in hit in the project settings, you'll be able to find this setting
here and then you'll just want to restart your editor again.
So Sequencer is a non-linear editing assembly tool.
You can create shots through the use of Sequencer.
We can create full film creation via Sequencer.
We do a lot of pre-visualization, which we'll be talking about here today.
And we also use it for game cinematic creation.
So if you're unsure what Sequencer is, it's a really powerful tool.
It's well worth knowing and diving into for what you might need for your projects.
If you are unfamiliar with what Sequencer is, definitely check out that documentation
link at the bottom of the page here.
There's a whole host of documentation sub pages there and a lot of tutorials to go from
with Sequencer.
And essentially what we can see here is we can see we've got a series of actors from
our scene that we've created.
So if we've got an eagle in the scene and we've got a meerkat in the scene, you can
see that we've added our actors from the scene into Sequencer.
And we'll maybe play an animation on those actors.
You can see that there's an animation track.
We also can set some kind of events from here.
So we're setting the visibility of the eagle for certain shots here.
So we can add and compose all these different actors essentially into the Sequencer to create
level sequence assemblies, which is the kind of key phrase that we're looking at here today.
So then when we look at this sequence in relation to how we might be approaching today's session,
you'll see that we have the eagle and the meerkat in the scene here.
And you can see as we scrub through, you can see the animation, the camera, the different
shots that set up.
And so that is the overall cinematic.
So that's the overall level sequence.
And what we can do here, we can nest the different sequences in a certain hierarchy for either
multiple people to be editing, to keep the content modular so you can move it around.
And so if you think of your overall film as this master sequence, this overall level sequence,
which is what we can see on the left hand side here, we can have some sequences, sometimes
referred to as sub sequences, which is maybe certain characters in a subsequence.
Maybe you can have a subsequence for all the audio that you put into the level.
You can have a subsequence for all the visual effects that you put in.
You can have various types of sequences, and it's up to you how you kind of handle and
organize that content.
But essentially it keeps it more modular and keeps it able to multiple people to work on
the same kind of film in one session.
So you can have multiple people per department, for example.
And then we can be working per shot where you can see we've got certain naming convention
set up so that people can be then double clicking on each one of these shots to open up the
expanded editor to really dial in a certain performance or we need some key audio add-in,
something like this.
So there's kind of a nested hierarchy going into this.
We can use this all in the take system, which we'll talk about in a few moments here.
So you can see how previously we were looking at sequencer without the E-POS tools available.
Now let's look at sequencer with the E-POS as a storyboarding generator tool.
So actors in the viewport or assets in the content browser are generated directly from
the sequencer to create level sequence assemblies.
So as before, they were added if we look, actors from the viewport or assets from the
content browser added into the sequencer.
So here we say they are generated.
So we add them all within sequencer to be viewed with this E-POS storyboard generator.
So we can see per shot here, we are generating various assets for the sequencer, again, for
this pre-visualization kind of storyboarding iterative approach.